Yeah,
a wise crack.
Did somebody.
Jared here,
I'm here today to talk to you about an
issue of grave importance,
a dark stain on our generation,
the Emoji movie.
Now you probably all know most of the
reasons to hate the Emoji movie.
It served as a family friendly vessel to
cram as many shameless product
placements as 90 minutes can fit.
It's also predictable,
painfully unfunny and tries to convey a
moral message as gracefully as this.
There's another reason you should hate
the Emoji movie.
It's politics and that's because while
it tries to tell a story about
inclusivity,
it's so poorly thought out.
That advantage is not only to fail at
being inclusive,
but accomplishes the exact opposite,
presenting us with a hopeless
totalitarian nightmare.
Seriously,
welcome.
This wise crack addition on the Emoji
movie,
what went wrong,
and just in case anyone gives us
spoilers ahead,
but first a recap.
The emoji movie takes place in Tech.
Stopple is a city of 70 into emojis.
Inside some kid named Alex his phone
gene,
a Emoji decides to stop mooching off his
parents and get a job in boating for his
human overlord problem is he has trouble
maintaining his madness,
expressing a range of emotions instead,
but since being met is his function,
he says,
job up gets labeled a malfunction
if you have expressions other than
function
and evades deletion from the text Apolis
Fas,
as the movie drags on his antics
threatened to kill him and everyone he
loves.
Once Alex tires have issues,
wireless wireless,
I'd like to make an appointment.
This phone is playing games with me.
He's just scape is assisted by princess
turned hacker and a high five who loves
to dance.
Alex decides to wipe his broken phone.
I wanted to leave everything to it.
Jean witnesses the deaths of all his
friends,
which is definitely his fault.
He manages to malfunction with
confidence and grace,
allowing Alex to properly mack on some
girl.
That's super cool.
Emoji.
In the end,
Alex is happy with his broken phone
because it's made him a mack daddy and
gene gets to express himself however he
pleases the end.
The emoji movie is certainly trying to
espouse a noble message that we are not
bound by tradition or birth and can
become whatever we want.
It's not a new trope.
The nobles overcome their birth name for
her bidden love a warrior who wants to
fight in spite of societal expectations
or pretty much any story where someone
packed their bags to escape their small
town existence or the big city
lifestyle.
It's an easy enough concept.
One,
you'd have to try really,
really hard to botch and with that,
the movie botched literally every single
opportunity to sell that message so much
so it's worth discussing.
Before we get into the totalitarian
stuff.
First there's jailbreak,
a princess Emoji by birth,
but she'd rather do cool hacker stuff
like wearing beanies and watching Mr.
robot,
instead of doing princess stuff
throughout film,
she assists gene and escaping to the
cloud.
Innovating deletion.
She eventually saves the day by throwing
away the hacker costume,
reverting to a princess and whistling
for the twitter bird.
In other words,
you can grow up to be anything you want,
but when push comes to shove,
you're going to have to sacrifice who
you are in order to become what society
always expected of you.
It kind of be like the plot of Milan,
but if Milan saved the day by going home
and cooking her father,
a nice dinner before folding his
laundry,
then there's gene who was born a man
Emoji,
but it's capable of laughing and
screaming and having sweet glasses.
He faces discrimination by not falling
in line with the identity society has
put out for him,
but a conversation between genes.
Parents reveals that his father has the
same malfunction,
suggesting that gene's malfunction is
gene netic.
Get it.
Jean,
regardless of whether or not emojis have
DNA,
the idea that genes whole identity is
inherited,
further undercuts the message that
society and birth shouldn't dictate what
we aspire to be and because bad
decisions apparently come in threes to
further cement the message that we all
contain some innate,
inescapable nature.
By birth,
the high five Emoji reminds us why he
has to press buttons.
It's a big red button and eventually
saves the day by performing the task he
was born to do.
Now,
that's not to say the movie can't be
trying to teach people to have
confidence in the things they can't
change about themselves,
but it also manages to more or less
demonstrate that you can achieve
greatness if your genetics allow.
It also manages to turn Internet trolls,
who in real life are horrible people by
their own volition into an identity that
one is born into and therefore can not
choose Emoji.
I thought the conversation just got
dahmer.
Internet trolls,
just ignore them so instead we get the
equivalent of a racial underclass
subject to constant denigration,
so much for inclusion,
but even if we wanted to concede that
the emoji movie really was about being
comfortable in your identity,
there's another scarier problem.
It offers us a vision of the future.
That to paraphrase George Orwell's 19,
84 is pretty much a boot stamping on an
Emoji face forever.
On one level,
the Emoji movie shows us an
authoritarian nightmare.
In it's emphatic,
fewer smiler emojis are put into the
service of the messaging APP and
anything that interferes with the
functioning of that APP must be
eliminated.
While gene supposedly overthrows this
order by flaunting his God given
talents,
what can we infer really happened to
text opolis afterwards to figure that
out,
we need a little help from German
philosopher Max Horkheimer Horkheimer
wrote extensively about an idea called
instrumental rationality or instrumental
reason and believe that played a crucial
role in the domination of humanity
throughout the 20th century,
especially into solitary and regimes.
Instrumental rationality is the kind of
reason we use to achieve a particular
end.
If I've decided the wise crack team
needs to eat,
50 pounds of pizza.
Instrumental reason can help me figure
out the best,
most efficient way for them to build
their bodies with regret.
Drink lots of water the day before.
Go for the toppings with high water
content.
Smoke lots of Ganja,
but instrumental rationality is
dangerous because it doesn't ask bigger
questions like,
why am I trying to destroy my body?
Or why in God's name did I just spend
$300 on pizza?
And while Horkheimer wasn't talking
about pizza or other everyday uses of
practical reason,
he noted that modern society was fueled
by this flawed kind of rationality,
always figuring out the fastest way to
get somewhere,
never trying to figure out if it was
even worth it at all.
Texts apolis seems to be run on this
kind of instrumental rationality.
The whole society is organized for one
purpose to deliver Alex the emojis.
He selects here.
Each of us does one thing and we have to
nail it every time.
There are never questions like,
why does Alex get to pick the Emoji?
Or Hey,
isn't this technically slavery?
And there's good reason if they go on
strike outs will probably uninstalled
the APP and murder them all.
See,
this is the problem with
anthropomorphizing utilities in films
where there are humans present.
It's cute at first,
but when you think about it,
it gets pretty horrified.
The problem with instrumental
rationality for Horkheimer is that it
aids in the domination of humanity since
it's concerned with questions like
efficiency and usefulness,
both nature and humanity become inputs
in the assembly line of society.
As we reduced our inner nature to
instrumental functions,
we lose any strong sense of self and
thus lack the inner substance in a
manner that makes us metaphorically into
nobody's and when everyone is reduced to
a use value,
things get even scarier.
It's for this reason that Horkheimer and
his fellow Frankfurt school thinkers
characterize the totalitarianism of the
19 thirties as the ultimate danger of
the instrumental rationality that
pervades our modern world.
We see the totalitarian danger of this
everywhere in the Emoji movie society is
organized based on how individual emojis
can be instrumentalized in the surface
of Alex.
emojis are used often get to go to the
cool parties and are popular with peers
while those unused get sent to the loser
lounge and those that disturb the peace.
As with gene get liquidated and while
the existential threat of getting
deleted,
they sound like good rationalization for
killing gene.
It's also worth noting that most
authoritarian regimes sell their message
through existential threats.
You know the whole,
it's either this or the demise of the
German people stick,
so it was gene's victory in the climax
of the film,
a blow against the authoritarian terror
of smiler.
Well,
no.
Yes,
Jean is a revered hero.
High five is popular again,
and the exclusive vip parties of the old
regime are now open to all from now on.
Welcome.
What is all this?
It's for you Jane.
However,
in the after credit scene,
we see smuggler relegated to the loser
lounge confirming a sill existing
between usable and unusable emojis,
but for Horkheimer,
this shouldn't be much of a surprise as
he writes what is usually indicated as a
goal.
The happiness of the individual health
wealth gains at significance exclusively
from its functional potentiality.
In other words,
the happiness of everyone in text opolis
is only significant in that Alex is
texting app still works.
Nothing is solved in regards to the
extreme instrumental rationality of
textile pollutes.
Emojis are still instrumentalized for
Alex,
and if gene's malfunction is now
popular,
it's only by the whims of their human
overlord.
We even get an Emoji dance where emojis
are seemingly free to emote as they
pleased,
but this expressiveness is only
permissible in so far as it doesn't
threaten Alex's social prowess,
and because the film hints that gene's
malfunction is inherited,
the implication is a new dystopia where
those with a quasi genetic mutation can
better serve Alex.
while those born of lesser genes can
still be discarded.
So while we may have thought that the
end of smilers regime would have meant
liberation of emotions and text Apolis,
the fact that Alex is still the ultimate
judge of functionality means nothing has
changed.
Basically,
the Emoji still live under the iron fist
of Alex because nothing has been done to
undermine their instrumentalization.
What will become of gene when Alex tires
have is ultimately meaningless?
Emoting one day he may decide to do away
with whatever money,
eyes slash kissing face slash
sunglasses,
emoji means and go straight for the
eggplant Emoji.
As if to foreshadow this high five tells
us early in the film
what you need off fans.
They give you complete an unrelenting
support as long as you're on top.
And here's the issue with making emojis,
which are things with an actual
function,
a metaphor for humans who are more than
a utility on a smartphone APP,
it makes a lot more sense to delete and
Emoji for not doing its job than
murdering a human for not doing its job
in textile apolis.
If the system truly goes too far,
Alex can just get another phone that's
not exactly how human civilization
works.
And here we can see the shift in how
domination happens.
Whereas 100 years ago,
the system enforced its rules with
repression like smilers,
our modern society strengthen their rule
with liberation or at least liberation
within bounds.
As fellow Frankfurt School Herbert
marcuse or wrote,
many of the freedoms afforded to western
civilization only served to make the
repression of those societies more
efficient.
We're given the freedom of how to exist
within the system,
but never the freedom to escape the
system.
The Post almost apocalypse world of text
habilis certainly seems more permissive,
but what has been omitted from the story
is the possibility of escape.
Jailbreak once resisted the system by
escaping it,
living outside the APP,
but now she's back in text apolis in
full princess the tire.
The cloud then represents the ultimate
resistance to the system which has been
brushed aside by the film and jeans.
Heroics have only served to perpetuate
this cruel system is the ultimate of the
Emoji movie.
Resistance is futile,
were either subjugated by strict
totalitarian regime or we get to express
ourselves freely,
so long as it serves the same master in
either case,
freedom is an illusion and your
inescapably a pawn in the system g you
all,
and thanks for watching.
Peace.
Yes.
What we have business to attend to.
What kind of business monkey business.
British,
thanks for watching wise crack.
If you need to cleanse your palate after
all that Emoji bashing and want to
celebrate what's good about movies
usually check out our friends over at
cinema winds.
They focus on the great stuff about
movies and they've already analyzed all
your favorite animated films including
Milana wreck it,
Ralph and big hero six.
Take a second to check them out,
including their newest video on patrols,
and be sure to subscribe while you're
over there and if you can't get enough
emoji movie,
which is something I thought I'd never
say.
Join Alec and I ranting a little more
about this train wreck on the newest
episode of our patron exclusive podcast,
wisecrack addition extra.
Become a patron and you can listen to
the podcast and check out a bunch more
exclusive content.
We've got a growing library of patron
only content with a lot more on the way,
like early access to videos,
podcast quick takes and more.
So check out our patrion page by
clicking here and don't forget to check
out cinema winds here and all those
links will be in the description to and
catch you all next time.
Peace.